The joe rogan experience cause kevin pereira just signed up for it.
Like that night at midnight,
he was on the computer signing up for Obamacare and I think he pays like $200 a
month or $300 a month for like really fucking awesome insurance because of it
now.
But uh,
it doesn't start until January,
I guess you have to sign up for nurses.
This is the sign up period.
They're trying to get everybody,
but like there's all these ads on TV telling you that it's bad and that you
shouldn't sign up for it.
They have ads that try to encourage young people to not sign up for it because
they have,
uh,
a young woman is sitting in like a gynecologist office with her feet in the
stirrups and then the gynecologist has a giant ugly,
uh,
Uncle Sam,
a paper say Uncle Sam head that rises up and it's like looming over her vagina.
Like trying to tell young people,
don't sign up for Obamacare because then they're gone.
Then the government's going to tell you what you can do with your vagina.
What was the true,
it was the government has a vagina agenda.
Well the thing is is they argue that Republicans do are,
are,
you know,
do have a vagina agenda.
But it's not too,
it's so weird that they've,
they basically have just flipped the script.
Like it's supposed to be that,
you know,
uh,
the Republicans are anti woman,
but they're trying to make it look like Obama's w really the one that wants to
tell you when,
what you could do with your vagina.
So it's just a manipulative,
it's about healthcare period.
So they use it to like sexual health care.
They go to that right away.
Babies,
Vagina.
Your wife's poss.
Yeah.
Well cause that's what the Democrats had been using.
They've been saying the Republicans are anti woman,
so this,
so they're just using the same approach but saying,
but putting it on Obamacare and Obamacare has anti woman,
it's really fascinating that they're allowed to do that.
It's really fascinated.
They're allowed to editorialize at all and that they're allowed to have like any
sort of dramatic influence at all and their commercials.
It's so crazy.
Like you're allowing people to manipulate.
You know,
Doug Benson has shown time and time again.
He doesn't care about the people of Los Angeles.
Doug Benson promotes smoking marijuana for underage children,
including your chilled trend.
Doug Benson is not a good American.
In fact,
he would live in Canada if it wasn't so fucking cold.
Doug Pencil president,
but they almost can say that man,
they can think they're so dramatic.
It's not facts like very clear,
simple,
vetted facts that have been verified on both sides and agreed to,
no,
no nonsense,
hyperbole,
drama,
dramatic writing,
fucking manipulation,
the truth,
all that standard fare and oh by the way,
we've been paid for by giant corporations.
It's a language.
They had an amazing spirit experiment in this book where Major League baseball
players,
almost all of them are off the charts.
Visually,
they have 2010 2017 vision.
There's almost no really great hitters there.
Don't think there are any
who have even 2020 vision.
They almost all without a doubt have vision that is off the charts there in the
1.1% I'm talking about all major league hitters,
uh,
and,
and the book is very eloquent and about this.
And so they took Albert Poo hosts and who and Alex Rodriguez and some incredible
hitters,
like the best of all time of their generation.
And they had um,
and one of the things they found is that when a baseball comes at you at 95
miles an hour from 60 feet away,
you have to guess where it's going.
You're not going to see it.
The human eye cannot register in time to actually see and hit the ball.
So what great hitters do is they're able to actually see the seams on the ball.
They're able to see the seams on the ball.
And so years and years of how those scenes are rolling and how that pitcher
throws the ball,
they're able,
if they're very good,
30% of the time they are able to predict and start swinging basically when he
lets go of the ball.
So that's where,
why curve balls and shit work.
Yes.
Because they can change where the ball's going to be changed direction.
But also the way you hit a curve off you're really great is you've,
you can see the way these guys can literally,
cause they have such good eyes can see the pattern of the red strings coming at
you at 95 miles an hour.
They can chunk all that information quickly enough and start swinging low as
opposed to hi and connect.
So you have to guess.
Now they take the greatest hitters in major league baseball and they take how
female Olympic softball pitcher who pitches underhand.
Now the distance is about 40 feet,
a little bit more than 40 feet.
The ball's coming over at about 60 miles an hour,
not 95 miles an hour.
And she pitches underhand.
Now these are the best pitchers and they hit a much smaller ball at 95 miles an
hour.
She struck out every single picture over and over and over again.
Because guess what?
There are novices,
cause you know why they couldn't guess.
They were looking at a very different ball.
They didn't have the strings and she was pitching underhand so they,
there was no way for them to predict anything.
They were swinging blind and they were as bad as you and I.
How about that?
That's amazing.
So the more you learn,
the more we learn.
Not only about you have to have a certain hardware.
We know as an athlete you are never going to be,
you and I are never going to be sprinters.
Sorry.
Shit.
The coverage from they learned from Ross Perot tell you what Ross Perot through
Daca and billion dollar monkey wrenching and they're fucking plans and folks who
were young and full of life.
You don't remember Ross Perot.
Ross Perot cost towards Bush's second term.
Yeah.
Ross Perot was a bad motherfucker.
That's why Clinton won.
He came around,
Ross Perot came around and all of the sudden there was this billionaire dude
explaining how the government works,
explaining the federal debt,
explaining the the f the Federal Bank explaining taxes and you're like,
wait,
what the fuck is going on?
He took time,
time on,
on network television.
That's what's so gangster about him.
Cause he was before the Internet.
This was not going when everybody was online.
This was like early nineties yeah.
You know what was there?
I remember here was it the Clinton election was 92 right?
Yeah.
92 yeah man.
I remember my friend John was like helping with his campaign ever helps them.
Anyways,
campaign.
He's like,
this motherfucker's going to get rid of all the crooks who was so excited about
them.
Yeah.
People were excited about Ross Perot was like the original Ron Paul.
Right.
But Ross Perot was way more gangster cause he had all that cash.
Yeah,
the money.
And he had a way of talking and saying,
yeah,
here's the problem.
Okay.
The crazy old ball fuck from down in Texas can tell she that was,
yeah,
that was a real interesting thing.
So from there they changed the commission for presidential debates or whatever
they call it,
which is a privately funded institution.
You know this corporations back it.
It's not,
it's not like it's a government program so they can decide who gets it.
Debate who doesn't.
There's a Ross.
What's crazy is because we have
I process in Washington where after you have Sarah for a while,
you can't,
she hadn't become a foreign lobbyists make $30,000 a month.
Then take a leave,
work on presidential campaigns,
make sure you got good contacts and then go back out there.
If you just want to get down to brass tacks,
first thing you ought to do is get all these folks,
they've got these one way trade agreements that we've negotiated over the air.
It's like tell us will take the same deal we gave you and they'll gridlock right
at that point because for example,
we've got international competitors who simply could not unload their cars off
the ships if they had to comply.
You say if it was a two way street,
just couldn't do it.
We have got to stop sending jobs overseas.
Probably give you in the audience your business paper.
Otherwise you'd be occupying China right now,
$14 an hour for factory workers and you can move your factor south the border.
Hey,
a dollar an hour for labor.
How are young 25 that's the same.
You've been in business for a long time.
You've got a mature workforce,
pay a dollar an hour for your library,
have no healthcare,
that's the most expensive single element.
Making a car,
have no environmental controls,
no pollution controls and no retirement.
And you don't care about anything but making money.
There will be a jab sucking sound going south.
So we,
if,
if the people send me to Washington,
the first thing,
how do I study that 2000 page agreement and make sure
I have one last point here.
I've called out undecided.
I was dumb and didn't understand it.
So I called a WHO's who of the folks who've been around it and I said,
why won't everybody go south?
They say it will be disruptive.
I said,
for how long?
I finally got them up for probably 15 years and I said,
well,
how does it stop being disruptive?
And that is when their jobs come up from a dollar now or $6 an hour and hours go
down to $6 an hour,
then it's leveled again.
But in the meantime,
you've wrecked the country where these kinds of deals,
holy shit.
Got to cut it out.
Thank you,
Mr. Right?
Holy Shit.
Ross Perot was calling shit in 1992 he was a gangster.
I mean,
how correct was that though?
You're a fucking human being.